Speaker 1: OK, it's time for the mailbag.
We do receive about, I don't know, few hundred
emails a day, but each week I will highlight
eight to 10 of them and go over them with
you. Sometimes there is interesting things,
sometimes there's nice compliments. Sometimes
there's toxic attacks and pejoratives a little
bit of everything. You can email info at David
Pakman dot com, but make sure you have something
really substantive to say. One person who
did not have something substantive to say
in any way is this person who actually sent
us a message via Facebook who said, You sir,
at least they're being polite. You, sir, are
a vile and disgusting piece of s. Your views
and opinions are treasonous, and you should
be locked in an effing loony bin alongside
Biden and his whore vice president. This,
I guess, is. Well, this is a lot of different
things, and I guess it's also misogynistic
among, I mean, we can't say what other, what
else it is, but it is very unhinged. We get
hundreds of messages like this every day.
And one of the really important things that
we should remember is, you know, when people
email me and they say politely, David, don't
you think you should do more to bridge the
gap between left and right? So that we can
kind of get people on our side and in our
way of thinking, Yeah, I'm for that. When
someone disagrees about the degree to which
business should be regulated or what the tax
rate should be, or how far we should go in
mitigating climate change. Please, those are,
you know, perfectly reasonable disagreements,
policy disagreements where we can have a conversation
and each person explains where they come from
and we might be able to change people's minds
or have productive conversation at minimum.
The person who sent this message, you can't
have that conversation with them. There's
nothing I can do to bridge the gap with this
person other than to throw myself at their
at their feet and say, I'm so wrong about
everything I believe, and you're so right.
And I'm such as this as this person, as a
vile and disgusting piece of whatever. There's
some of these people are so far gone. There
is no way to bridge the gap, and so we've
got to go around them. They're not going to
be with us. They're not you. No matter what
tone I adopt on this program, this person
is not going to have a productive conversation.
OK? Next email from Jane about the outdoor
ski resort mask policy in Canada, Jane said.
I don't think you criticize the lack of masks
at the indoor State of the Union address,
or the fact that California lifted its indoor
mask mandate on February 16. But you did complain
about the maskless snowboarder in Ontario.
Do you honestly think there's a qualified,
nonpolitical scientist who thinks masks should
be mandatory outdoors at this stage for vaccinated
folks? You claim to follow scientific advice,
but you choose to disregard it when it doesn't
suit your narrative. Listen. What on earth
are you responding to, ma'am? I made clear
when we looked at a video of a dad throwing
a tantrum and having to be grabbed by five
security people on an outdoor ski lift. I
said in that he went there knowing that was
the policy I have said almost since the beginning
of the pandemic, it started with, I don't
know that we really need masks outside. And
then we had data and then I said, we definitely
don't need masks outside unless people are
literally on top of each other and, you know,
insane situations. I've said it from the beginning
and indeed the State of the Union. The rules
were you don't have to wear a mask. So Jane,
this isn't about my opinion about when masks
are and aren't necessary. I've already said
I don't think the masks outdoors are necessary
because that's what the science has shown.
The dad humiliating himself and his family
throwing a temper tantrum because he wouldn't
wear a mask. The problem is he's acting like
a like a little kid, and he knew the rules.
If I don't want to wear a mask somewhere,
like, let me give you an example. At gyms
for the entire pandemic, you had to wear a
mask regardless of whether I thought it was
necessary. And I basically did, for the most
part. I don't want to wear a mask while working
out. So you know what I did? I canceled my
gym membership. I'm not interested in working
out and being on a treadmill with a mask on.
But if I choose to go to the gym and I know
what the rule is, I'm going to abide by the
rule. The guy on the ski lift knew what the
rule was, and he ignored it. That's the problem.
It's not about my opinion about masking. The
Oracle wrote in and said Jonestown was not
a mass suicide. Criticizing me, I welcome
it. This is at least the second time you talk
about the mass suicide at Jonestown, it was
not a mass suicide. You can maybe call it
a mass murder suicide, but many argue it just
be a mass murder. People were forced to drink
the drink, and those who refused were shot,
calling it mass suicide. Sounds like everyone
did it of their own free will. Yeah, this
is fair. I should call the Jonestown Massacre
a murder suicide. There were a bunch of people
there who willingly took the flavor aid or
Kool-Aid or whatever it was because they had
been brainwashed. They did take it willingly.
Some did not, and some were shot. The children
were forcibly injected with it. I will do.
I will do better. Oracle and I will refer
to what happened in Jonestown with Jim Jones
in South America as a mass murder suicide.
I appreciate the correction, Walter wrote
in said Biden will pardon Trump and nobody's
talking about it. I don't know about that.
I don't think Trump's going to be charged
with anything, so for that reason, I don't
expect Biden to pardon Trump, but I know that
at times past there has been this idea in
the United States that we don't go after former
presidents criminally, and so we have seen
pardons. But Joe Biden has given no indication
that that's what he would do now. Maybe Walter
knows something I don't. Or maybe Walter speculating
or whatever the case may be, but I have no
reason to believe that Joe Biden would would
pardon Donald Trump if he were charged. I
don't think Trump's going to be charged with
anything, as I've said before. Hayley wrote
in Could Putin have dementia? She asks. Hey,
David, longtime fan of your show and one of
your latest videos, you talked about Putin
being possibly terminally ill and that being
a reason that he's attacking Ukraine. Do you
think it's possible Putin has dementia? He
seems to be overly suspicious of Ukraine and
the West, like he is paranoid of everyone.
What are your thoughts on this? There is no
way. I mean, listen. Delusional paranoia is
sometimes a symptom of dementia. Sometimes
they really are out to get you. Sometimes
some combination of both. There's just no
way to know. And I understand when you see
these pictures of Putin at a 50 foot long
table away from his own advisers, you think,
well, either he's really afraid of germs or
he's sick and whatever, or he thinks one of
them may try to kill him. And that's paranoia.
But I have to tell you, it doesn't seem completely
unwarranted. I mean, it's conceivable. Maybe
somebody would try to kill him? I don't know.
So I think Hayley, as much as I appreciate
the the hypothesis or the idea, I just don't
think I don't think there's any way for us
to know right now. And it may be the type
of thing that we could know in retrospect
at some point in the future. Scott wrote in
about the alt left and says, I'm really glad
that you're being authentic and speaking your
mind against all sides that are counter to
your ideas ideals. Keep up the great work,
and I look forward to seeing your show continue
to grow. Yeah, you know, I've received a bunch
of emails recently from saying, David, I really
appreciate the courage to call out other leftists
that you have. First of all, I don't really
think that they're leftists, to be perfectly
honest, like when I look at Tulsi Gabbard.
What is there that's I mean, she she's vaguely
against wars, but like so is Trump supposedly,
you know, this is not a program where things
are off limits or we have sacred cows or whatever.
I just call things what they are. And it just
so happens that with the Russia Ukraine situation,
a lot of these so-called leftists are saying
very strange things. And so I'll tell you
when I when I see that, Andrew wrote in about
the word anomaly, David, I am a geologist
who works in an industry that deals in a lot
in anomalies. I am going to lay down the law
and proclaim your original pronunciation is
correct. The correct version begins sounding
like the word anonymous. If anyone who wishes
to disagree with me, I challenge them to a
game of Mario Kart. Now, listen, I have to
tell you, I'm getting a little sick of the
anomaly anomaly thing. Go to the Merriam-Webster
dictionary type in the word A. M. A. L Y,
and you will see in the pronunciation section.
Both pronunciations are fine. Anomaly like
a garden gnome anomaly. Anomaly. Both are
fine, and quite frankly, I'm getting a little
sick of having to defend that. Fred wrote
in about Russian COVID. David, I hear so much
about the Russian invasion, but one thing
that's not mentioned what's going on with
COVID in Russia and is it or could it be an
issue? Has Russia solved the pandemic and
needs something to fear? Or is the Ukraine
invasion a distraction from COVID? No, I don't.
I mean, there's there's there's still COVID
in Russia. There is no reason to believe that
we've got an accurate data from Russia from
the beginning, and I don't think it's transparent.
What is happening with COVID in Russia? But
Russia has not solved COVID, but it seems
completely reasonable that, like most of the
world, not all of the world, but most of the
world, there has been a three month to month,
I guess, decline in COVID cases and hospitalizations
and death. I would assume that's what's going
on there. But I don't have any particular
reason to think that COVID is quote over in
Russia, and I don't think the invasion of
Ukraine has anything to do with COVID. If
you have a different perspective, certainly
let me know. Reminder we are launching the
David Pakman show coaching. This is a little
this is an interesting new project we're doing.
I am going to try to help others grow their
online platforms. So if you are already a
content creator, OK, if you're not, this isn't
for you. This isn't to teach people how to
start. If you are already a content creator
and you have a YouTube channel with an audience
or a podcast with an audience, and you're
all good on the production side and you want
to participate in some group coaching, I am
going to be coaching for maybe five people
in a group format. You can sign up at David
Pakman dot com slash coaching. You have to
be willing to have our coaching sessions filmed
because then we're going to publish them to
hopefully help even more people. OK, that's
the idea. If you're not interested, just don't
do anything. I got two emails from people
angry and they don't want to do it, but then
don't sign up if you if you don't want to
be coached on growing an independent media
platform, do nothing. OK, but if you want
to be, you can go to David Pakman dot com
slash coaching. Fill out that form. We've
got a great bonus show for you today coming
up right after this short break. Sign up at
Join Pacman Dot Com to get access
Unidentified: to the bonus show, otherwise
we'll see you on Monday.